[Music]
time to debate Lincoln boy you didn't
like Lincoln I liked it about as much as
you can like a two-and-a-half-hour
history lesson yeah this film strips
these to show us back in high school
yeah it was about as entertaining as one
of those that is a huge overstatement
and you know it is is it yes it is is
this or is it not at the end of the day
I movie that's about the passing of a
piece of legislation it is might as well
be an episode of The West Wing circa
1865 but less snappy banter that's a
good joke but it's not remotely accurate
and you know it that was easy
do you ever get tired of losing these
debates to me the qatari are you scoring
points without an actual debate but I
can do it too Daniel day-lewis was
awesome this movie and there could be no
argument that was easy will you need
some we've been better what what'd you
say nothing all right my turn to speak
to fine
know what the speed to fire this you
know how I knew Daniel day-lewis was
gonna win the Oscar for this movie
because every other scene is a speech
soliloquy or big storytelling moment for
Lincoln it only scenes that aren't big
Lincoln speeches are when he's walking
from place to place in between two big
Lincoln's Beatles I think Lincoln
himself was prone to speeches and
stories characters all he ever did in
his old time in life it doesn't make for
good cinema I might as well call it best
actor the movie now I'm with you because
the speechifying is what made the movie
good are you can't just go scoring
points you know you know when I get the
score points or something like that
now now now that was easy your dick not
as big a dick as Lincoln was to his son
and that's my next point
how can a movie that celebrates a cold
distant emotionally abusive father like
this as the hero be considered a good
movie worked for Star Wars another
problem no suspense no suspense you've
got to be kidding me
there's no suspense in this movie from
the first few minutes I knew they were
gonna pass that legislation that's
because it happened in real life
exactly bad writing way too predictable
that was easy you feel the same way
about Apollo 13 that was Apollo 13 real
yes yes taking the point either way
right and I'm also taking a point to the
ending when they pop out and try and
show us death you can't do a Lincoln
movie without showing this death then
and show it right don't flash forward
allude to it and then flash back to
another speech all right have the balls
to show it if you're gonna show it but
you spent two and a half hours telling
me this movie was about the legislation
not the assassination all right so then
have the balls to end it without comping
out going to the assassination stupid I
think maybe you I'm also taking a point
because Lincoln Thursday's Lincoln is
dirty he's dirty man he hires those
lobbyists to bribe intimidate coerce he
basically buys the vote all right so
this movie's conclusion is dirty
politics is okay as long as you're right
and that doesn't work because every
politician thinks they're right and they
can't all be right Thank You shin
superior at all then you probably think
the earth is flat course are you
don't be ridiculous with this round
dumbass that's what I said shut up I
know what I said
[Music]